let P of T denote the number of people P
at the Copacabana beach in Rio de
Janeiro T hours past midnight on a
specific day what does the statement P
of 5 less than P of 9 mean so let's
before I even read this let's think
about this so this is the number of
people 5 hours past midnight on a
specific day so this is saying that the
number of people 5 hours past midnight
is less than the number of people 9
hours past midnight at Copacabana beach
so the number of people 5 hours past
midnight is less than the number of
people 9 hours past midnight
let's look at these choices the time at
which there were 5 people at the beach
is earlier than the time there were 9
people
well no the five and the nine aren't the
number of people this is the time this
was the input into the function the
input into the function is time this
gives people as a function of time you
give a time you give a time this
function P it outputs P of T which is
equal to the number of people number of
people on the beach at time at time T so
this 5 this is the input this is the
time 5 hours after or I not in session C
at time T so I guess you could say a.m.
time T hours past midnight at T hours
past midnight hours past past midnight
midnight so we can definitely rule this
out this isn't talking about five people
and nine people this is talking what
five hours after midnight is input and
how many people we have five hours after
midnight is how many people we have nine
hours after midnight 5:00 a.m. is an
earlier time than 9:00 a.m. well that is
a true statement but that's not what
this statement is saying it's not this
isn't giving us information we just know
from I guess how we think about time how
we measure time that 5:00 a.m. is rather
than item but that's not what this
statement is trying to say
so we'll rule that out there were more
people at the beach at 9:00 a.m. so to
be clear people at the beach
I am that's that right over here then
there were then there were at 5:00 a.m.
then there were at 5:00 a.m. well that's
right over there and we see where we see
that this quantity here is greater than
those magenta quantity is indeed greater
than this green quantity or the green
quantity is less than the magenta
quantity so we would definitely pick
that one